This is 99% Infisible. I'm Roman Mars. You're listening to our second episode of short stories all about what may be the original designed object, the trail. If you haven't heard the first episode yet, you should totally go back and listen to it. It's a lot of fun. We're going to kick off this second episode with another conversation with author and trail expert Robert Moore. Robert wrote an excellent book called On Trails. I cannot recommend it highly enough. If you listen to the previous episode,
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。你正在收听我们关于“或许是最初的设计对象——步道”的短篇故事系列的第二集。如果你还没听过第一集，一定要回去听听，非常有趣。这一集我们将从与作家兼步道专家罗伯特·摩尔（Robert Moore）的再次对话开始。罗伯特写了一本非常棒的书，叫《步道之上》（On Trails），我强烈推荐。如果你听过上一集，
you heard him explore the origins of trails and the way they're shaped by culture. Today, Robert Moore is back to talk about his first hand experience, hiking and learning about one of the longest, most iconic trails in America. So Robert, your book begins with you talking about this huge challenge of hiking the Appalachian Trail, otherwise known as the AT.
你已经听他探讨了步道的起源以及它们是如何被文化塑造的。今天，罗伯特·摩尔回来分享他亲身徒步并了解美国最长、最具标志性的步道之一的经历。那么罗伯特，你的书开头谈到了徒步阿帕拉契小径（Appalachian Trail，简称AT）这一巨大挑战。
Can you describe what the AT is and why it's such a massive undertaking to hike it? The Appalachian Trail is a roughly 2,000 mile path that basically follows the spine in the Appalachian Mountains. So it goes from Georgia to Maine, takes about three to six months to walk. I did it in about five. And it's five months of continuous hiking on a trail that follows a very rough route. A lot of other hiking trails, nowadays, have been graded for horses so that they will never go above a certain incline. The Appalachian Trail is much older than that. It's America's
你能描述一下AT是什么，以及为什么徒步它是一项如此艰巨的任务吗？阿帕拉契小径是一条全长约2000英里的路径，基本上沿着阿帕拉契山脉的脊线延伸。它从佐治亚州一直延伸到缅因州，走完全程大约需要三到六个月。我用了大约五个月。这是五个月不间断的徒步，路线非常崎岖。如今，许多其他徒步小径为了马匹通行而进行了平整，坡度永远不会超过一定限度。而阿帕拉契小径要古老得多。它是美国
oldest, very long trail. And so even though the mountains of the Appalachians are not as high as what you'd find in Colorado or California, it's just really arduous on a day-to-day basis. I think for that reason, it's become a kind of American pilgrimage. And you write in your book that the Appalachian Trail, it really started out as this radical idea. It was the first really long trail in the US, but it also has a lot of philosophy and high-minded
最古老的超长步道。因此，尽管阿帕拉契山脉不像科罗拉多州或加利福尼亚州的山脉那样高，但它每天的行程都非常艰苦。我认为正是因为这个原因，它已经成为了一种美国式的朝圣之旅。你在书中写道，阿帕拉契小径最初是一个激进的想法。它是美国第一条真正意义上的长距离步道，但它背后也蕴含着许多哲学和崇高的
sort of notions about its existence. Could you talk about the origins of the trail itself? Yeah, so the person who came up with the Appalachian Trail as a guy by the name of Benton MacKai. And he had a dream of this wilderness space that would mirror the industrial belt way of the East Coast. And so it would be a place where the workers of the East Coast could escape to go up into the mountains, kind of refresh their spirits. And so, oddly, his original notion was not that people would be walking the entire trail in one go. That wasn't really something that was on his mind.
关于其存在的理念。你能谈谈这条步道本身的起源吗？是的，提出阿帕拉契小径构想的人叫本顿·麦凯（Benton MacKaye）。他梦想着建立一个荒野空间，与东海岸的工业带相呼应。这样，东海岸的工人们就可以逃离城市，走进山林，让精神焕然一新。奇怪的是，他最初的构想并不是让人一次性走完整个步道。那根本不在他的考虑范围内。
He was seeing it as a way of connecting a variety of recreation centers, even a kind of sanatorium, work farms, all of these outdoor sources of mental and physical health that he wanted to run all the way up these coast. And the funny thing that happened was people love the idea of the trail and not so much the rest of that other stuff. So that stuff kind of withered away
他将其视为连接各种娱乐中心、甚至疗养院、工作农场的一种方式，他希望沿着海岸线建立所有这些能促进身心健康的户外资源。有趣的是，人们喜欢步道的构想，但对其他那些东西却不怎么感兴趣。所以那些东西逐渐消失了，
and what was left was this continuous line that people still to this day follow in a way that Benton Mekai had never intended. And what do you think it didn't take off in that way? I don't think Mekai properly anticipated how the culture of the Appalachian Trail would evolve. I don't think he knew how popular long distance Trail would evolve. I don't think he knew how popular long distance hiking would become, and I don't think he knew how this era of heroism or a sort of epic nature of the Appalachian Trail
剩下的就是这条连续的线路，人们至今仍以本顿·麦凯从未预料到的方式行走其上。你认为为什么它没有按他预想的那样发展？我不认为麦凯充分预料到了阿帕拉契小径的文化会如何演变。我不认为他知道长距离徒步会变得如此受欢迎，也不认为他预料到这种英雄主义时代或阿帕拉契小径的史诗性质
would congeal in the American imagination. I don't think he could have known that until a guy by the name of Earl Schaefer went and hiked the entire trail in one go. When Earl Schaeffer did that, people didn't even believe him. He had to prove that he'd done it using photographs and his diary. And so I think that Benton McCuy was actually in an odd way looking at the Appalachian Trail in a way that's very similar to how we currently look at wilderness, which is as as a kind of source of mental and physical health, almost in a medicinal way, but also in a utopian way, a place where
会在美国人的想象中凝结成形。我认为在厄尔·谢弗（Earl Shaffer）一次性走完全程之前，他是不可能知道这些的。当厄尔·谢弗做到这一点时，人们甚至不相信他。他不得不利用照片和日记来证明自己完成了壮举。所以我认为，本顿·麦凯以一种奇怪的方式看待阿帕拉契小径，这与我们目前看待荒野的方式非常相似，即将其视为一种身心健康的源泉，几乎是一种药用方式，同时也是一种乌托邦式的存在，一个我们可以
we could go to form community and to improve the civic spirit. That is something that the American form of wilderness travel is not really worried itself with what we've worried about is going out as individuals into the wilderness proving our metal having sublime experiences of these beautiful mountains and forests and that is what the hiking aspect of the Appalachian Trail provided. person to hike the whole, like, original AT in one season. And he, he wrote, like, I almost wish the trail really was endless that no one could ever hike its length. And what is that desire? You know, like, I think a lot of people think of trails as maybe getting from one place to another. But there seems to be this alternate desire to extend and extend and extend and never have the man. Well, a funny thing happens when you finish the Appalachian Trail, which is you feel kind
去建立社区和提升公民精神的地方。这并不是美国式荒野旅行真正关心的问题，我们关心的是作为个人走进荒野，证明自己的勇气，在这些美丽的群山和森林中获得崇高的体验，而这正是阿帕拉契小径的徒步方面所提供的。第一个在一个季节内走完整个原始AT的人。他写道：“我甚至希望这条步道真的是无止境的，没有人能走完它的全程。”那种渴望是什么？你知道，我想很多人认为步道只是从一个地方到另一个地方的途径。但似乎还有一种想要不断延伸、延伸、再延伸，永远不要结束的替代性渴望。嗯，当你走完阿帕拉契小径时，会发生一件有趣的事，那就是你会感到一种
of sad, you know. You think that it's going to be this joyous moment. And as I was approaching Katad and I remember every day, I would have the thought, oh, what if I twist my ankle? What if I fall and I can't hike anymore? And I would knock on wood. You know, thankfully there's a lot of wood around on the Appalachian Trail.
悲伤。你以为那会是一个欢乐的时刻。当我接近卡塔丁山（Katahdin）时，我记得每天我都会想：噢，如果我扭伤了脚踝怎么办？如果我摔倒了，再也不能徒步了怎么办？我会敲敲木头。你知道，谢天谢地，阿帕拉契小径上到处都是木头。
But I was doing this multiple times a day, literally knocking on wood multiple times a day, thinking I just want to get to the end. I just want to get to the end because I don't want to fall short of my goal. And then when you get there, you realize that, you know that there's no more trail. You've come to the end.
但我每天都要这样做很多次，真的每天敲好几次木头，心想我只想走到终点。我只想走到终点，因为我不想在目标面前功亏一篑。然后当你到达那里时，你意识到，你知道，没有更多的步道了。你已经走到了尽头。
And there's a sadness. And I think anyone who's read a really great book knows that feeling where you get to the last page and you think, I wish it kept going. And so there are people who do all sorts of things to try to extend that experience. They'll walk from Georgia to Maine and they'll turn around and go back to Georgia. Or they'll walk the Appalachian Trail every year. It's like we want to be able to continue on the pilgrimage without it ending because it is such a beautiful experience. So after you walk the entire length of the Appalachian Trail, it's 2,181 miles. You yourself decided that you wanted to extend that experience and you went on to walk something called the International Appalachian Trail.
有一种悲伤感。我想任何读过一本好书的人都知道那种感觉，当你读到最后一页时，你会想：我希望它能继续下去。所以有些人会做各种各样的事情来试图延长那种体验。他们会从佐治亚州走到缅因州，然后掉头走回佐治亚州。或者他们每年都走阿帕拉契小径。就像我们希望能够继续这场朝圣之旅而不让它结束，因为它是一次如此美好的体验。所以，在你走完阿帕拉契小径的全长，即2181英里后，你自己决定想要延长那种体验，并继续去走所谓的“国际阿帕拉契小径”。
So what is the International Appalachian Trail? Basically a guy named Dick Anderson who lived up in Maine was looking at and maps one day and he realized that the logic of the Appalachian Trail is that it follows the Appalachian Mountains. And yet the Appalachian Mountains don't end at Mount Catadon. The Appalachian Mountains. And yet, the Appalachian Mountains don't end in Mount Kitatin. The Appalachian Mountains keep going up through Canada. So we thought, well, why not make the trail longer? Why not just keep going as if the border doesn't exist? And in that way, it was kind of a subtly political act as well,
那么什么是国际阿帕拉契小径？基本上，一个住在缅因州的叫迪克·安德森（Dick Anderson）的人，有一天在看地图时意识到，阿帕拉契小径的逻辑是它沿着阿帕拉契山脉延伸。然而，阿帕拉契山脉并没有在卡塔丁山结束。阿帕拉契山脉一直延伸到加拿大。所以他想，为什么不把步道延长呢？为什么不就这么一直走下去，仿佛边界不存在一样？从某种意义上说，这甚至是一种微妙的政治行为，
to go beyond borders, to imagine a world without borders. And so that's exactly what he did. He extended the trail farther and farther. And then as soon as he got to Newfoundland, he started talking to geologists. And the geologists said to him, well, you know, the Appalachians don't really end in Newfoundland either. The Appalachians are also over in Europe because when the Appalachian Mountains formed, they were this kind of seam that split along the coast of North America on the east side and then the west side of Europe. And so you could continue following the Appalachian geology if you really wanted to down through all of Europe into North Africa.
去跨越边界，去想象一个没有边界的世界。这正是他所做的。他把步道延伸得越来越远。然后当他到达纽芬兰时，他开始与地质学家交谈。地质学家告诉他，嗯，你知道，阿帕拉契山脉在纽芬兰也没有真正结束。阿帕拉契山脉在欧洲也有分布，因为当阿帕拉契山脉形成时，它们就像是北美东海岸和欧洲西海岸之间的一道裂缝。所以如果你真的想的话，你可以继续沿着阿帕拉契地质结构，穿过整个欧洲，一直走到北非。
And that was a really mind-blowing idea that I think Dick Anderson really likes. We are now entering this weird post-modern realm where a trail becomes a kind of text, you know, where a trail is aligned on a map, a trail is an idea, a trail is a story, a trail is a collection of scientific data surrounding geology, it becomes really tricky to pin down what a trail is if we're going to say that you can walk from Georgia to Morocco. But at the end of the day, I think a trail is a story. A trail is a story we tell ourselves about why we're following a certain route and why we're taking that journey.
那是一个非常令人震撼的想法，我想迪克·安德森真的很喜欢。我们现在进入了一个奇怪的后现代领域，步道变成了一种文本，你知道，步道是地图上的一条线，步道是一个想法，步道是一个故事，步道是围绕地质学的科学数据集合。如果我们说你可以从佐治亚州一直走到摩洛哥，那么定义什么是步道就变得非常棘手。但归根结底，我认为步道就是一个故事。步道是我们告诉自己的故事，关于我们为什么要走某条路线，为什么要踏上那段旅程。
It's what gives the journey significance in some sense. It's a kind of myth, we tell ourselves. Yeah, yeah. I think originally when I was walking on trails I had this feeling that there was something slightly conformist, you know, that I should have been this pathbreaker. I should have been someone breaking new ground. But after writing this book, after spending all this time, thinking about what a trail really is, now when I walk a trail I see myself as taking part in this collective creation of meaning,
这在某种意义上赋予了旅程意义。这是我们告诉自己的某种神话。是的，是的。我想最初我在走步道时，有一种感觉，觉得这有点随大流，你知道，我本应该是一个开拓者。我本应该是一个开辟新天地的人。但在写完这本书，花这么多时间思考步道到底是什么之后，现在当我走在步道上时，我把自己看作是参与了这种集体意义创造的一部分，
really the making of meaning out of chaos, which is the most fundamental thing that we as human beings do. And there's something really, really beautiful in that. Fans of the show who have read our book, the 99% visible city co-authored by Krakow Stead and myself, know that desire paths are trails created not by design, but rather carved out by foot traffic as people take the path they desire and wear them in over time. Hollowways, or simply one word, hollowways, are desire paths gone wild, reflecting centuries or even millennia of informal use. They often start as flat paths and they get carved into the ground by things going over
真正地从混沌中创造意义，这是我们作为人类所做的最根本的事情。这其中确实有一些非常、非常美妙的东西。读过我们书的粉丝们，即由克拉科·斯特德（Krakow Stead）和我合著的《99%无形城市》（The 99% Invisible City），都知道“欲望路径”（desire paths）是指那些并非由设计产生，而是随着人们走自己想走的路，久而久之踩踏出来的步道。“空心路”（Holloways），或者简单地说“空心路”，是狂野版的欲望路径，反映了几个世纪甚至几千年的非正式使用。它们通常始于平坦的小径，随着东西一次又一次地经过，
them again and again and again. Some of them are so deep, they look look like long sunken half-pipes. Many hollowways and places like Europe have been eroded over the centuries by a combination of foot traffic, farm animals, laden carts, and rivers of water. The word hollow way itself has been traced back to the old English hollow-wegg meaning sunken road. Many of the actual half tunnels though are thought to date all the way back to Roman times. They are often particularly deep in places where the ground is soft, containing high amounts of sandstone and chalk. Today's some holoays have been made more official, you can find an especially long network of these sunken paths in Germany. But across the world, many holoays are doing just what they've always done, forming themselves slowly and steadily under our feet.
被刻入地面。有些深到看起来像长长的下沉式半管。欧洲等地的许多空心路在几个世纪里被行人、农场动物、满载的马车和流水共同侵蚀而成。“空心路”这个词本身可以追溯到古英语“hollow-wegg”，意为下沉的道路。不过，许多真正的半隧道被认为可以追溯到罗马时代。它们在土壤松软、含有大量砂岩和白垩的地方通常特别深。如今，一些空心路变得更加正式，你可以在德国找到一个特别长的下沉路径网络。但在世界各地，许多空心路正在做它们一直以来所做的事情，在我们脚下缓慢而稳定地形成。
For our next trail story, 99PI producer and editor Kelly Prime recorded her journey on a bike trail that begins not in a remote forest or a mountain range, but in one of the most densely populated urban centers in the country. I am on the Empire State Trail, which is this insanely long, like 750 mile long trail you can take from New York City to Canada, Albany to Buffalo, and you know you think a trail needs to be, you know, in wilderness, pastoral, but actually you've got trails in the city too, at least partly. It can get you surprisingly far on two wheels. We're gonna keep going on this trail all the way up to Crotten Point
对于我们的下一个步道故事，99PI制作人兼编辑凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）记录了她在一条自行车道上的旅程，这条步道不是始于偏远的森林或山脉，而是始于全国人口最稠密的城市中心之一。我正在帝国州步道（Empire State Trail）上，这是一条长得离谱的、大约750英里长的步道，你可以从纽约市一直骑到加拿大，从奥尔巴尼到布法罗。你知道，你以为步道需要是在荒野、田园风光中，但实际上城市里也有步道，至少部分是这样。它能让你在两个轮子上走得惊人地远。我们将继续沿着这条步道一直骑到克罗顿角（Croton Point），
which is about a almost a 50 mile bike ride from New York. One eternity later. We're in Crotten Point Park right now. Little campsite with some swimming just finished our coffee. We are packing up camp. We biked for many hours yesterday So what I'm looking at we've got two tons set up for bikes leading up against a tree pennier stuff with stuff I think we're all feeling a little tired,
距离纽约大约有近50英里的自行车程。一个永恒之后。我们现在在克罗顿角公园。这里有个小露营地，可以游泳，刚喝完咖啡。我们正在收拾营地。我们昨天骑了好几个小时。所以我现在看到的是，我们搭了两个帐篷，自行车靠在树上，行李装在驮包里。我想我们都觉得有点累，
little sore after yesterday, but we are about to start our return into the city, coming back the way we came. Like how are you feeling about our trip back in New York. Pretty pumped. Just hoping you had your rain back. Yeah. 12 seconds later. It's raining. How's the feel back there? I'm flashing. Refreshing! 5 points and waiting area. Yes, that's your goal. Congratulations. Thank you for your collaboration. Started raining really hard. Got this old bike.
昨天之后有点酸痛，但我们马上要开始返回城市，原路返回。你对我们回纽约的行程感觉如何？挺兴奋的。只希望你带了雨具。是的。12秒后。下雨了。后面感觉怎么样？我湿透了。清爽！5分和等候区。是的，那是你的目标。恭喜。谢谢你的合作。开始下大雨了。这辆旧自行车。
The brakes are not working right. So we are going home on the Metro North, which will take us from Austin, up here, down to 125th in Harlem. But it's been a good trip so far We can see the convenience of that train on the trail That has room for bikes And it was free time we need to go. It's amazing. It's almost like a trail of its own.
刹车不太好用。所以我们要坐大都会北方铁路（Metro North）回家，它会带我们从奥西宁（Ossining）一直到哈莱姆区的125街。但到目前为止，这是一次不错的旅行。我们可以看到那列火车在步道上的便利性，它有放自行车的地方。而且那是免费的，我们需要出发了。太棒了。它几乎就像一条属于它自己的步道。
You haven't seen that? One might say that. For a podcast. Oh, it's a suit. Frequent campers and hikers probably know the word gorp, but for those who don't, it's spelled G-O-R-P, all caps, and it's another name for trail mix. This mix of oats, nuts, chocolate raisins, and other ingredients for on-the-go energy dates back over a century, though the term trail mix wasn't popularized until the 1960s and 70s. In other places, these mixes go by other names too, like Scrogan in New Zealand and Australia.
你没见过那个吗？有人可能会这么说。为了播客。噢，这很合适。经常露营和徒步的人可能知道“Gorp”这个词，但对于不知道的人，它是全大写的G-O-R-P，是“什锦干果”（trail mix）的另一个名字。这种由燕麦、坚果、巧克力、葡萄干和其他提供随身能量的成分组成的混合物，其历史可以追溯到一个多世纪前，尽管“trail mix”这个词直到20世纪60年代和70年代才流行起来。在其他地方，这些混合物也有其他名字，比如新西兰和澳大利亚的“Scrogan”。
That's my personal favorite. In America, trail mix has become a useful generic, but Gorp is still a popular shorthand for those in the know. But where did that strange name come from? According to recreational equipment ink, better known as REI, Gorp might stand for good old raisins and peanuts, or maybe Cranola oats, raisins and peanuts, but there are other possible explanations too. A century old definition for the word Gorp suggests that it meant to eat greedily, and if
那是我的个人最爱。在美国，什锦干果已经成为一个有用的通用词，但Gorp对于内行来说仍然是一个流行的简写。但这个奇怪的名字是从哪里来的呢？根据REI（Recreational Equipment Inc.）的说法，Gorp可能代表“Good Old Raisins and Peanuts”（好的老葡萄干和花生），或者可能是“Cranola oats, raisins and peanuts”，但还有其他可能的解释。一个关于Gorp这个词的百年定义表明，它意味着“贪婪地吃”，如果
that's true, that would make gorp a backer-nam. As in, an acronym created after the fact based on letters already in an existing word. Like almost every government program that spells something like the CARES Act is a backer-nam. Whatever the origin, the word gorp has more recently been incorporated into a portmanteau tied with another aspect of trail-centric lifestyles, wilderness chic apparel. Here to tell us all about that is Avery Trophiman. Hello.
那是真的，那Gorp就是一个“回溯词”（backronym）。就像是在已经存在的单词字母基础上事后创造的首字母缩写。就像几乎每一个拼写出某种含义的政府项目，比如“CARES法案”，都是回溯词。无论起源如何，Gorp这个词最近被融入了一个与步道生活方式的另一个方面——“荒野时尚”（wilderness chic）服装——相关的合成词中。来为我们讲述这一切的是艾弗里·特罗菲曼（Avery Trufelman）。你好。
Avery is the host and creator of Articles of Interest and today she's here to talk about Gorp Kor. So Avery, can you tell me what Gorp Kor is and where it came from? I feel as though sort of post quarantine, we all sort of emerged from our hideaways and everyone was like, what's going on? Guys, what are we all wearing? And the answers were like, no, core, Barbie core, bistro core. It's like, what is going on? But
艾弗里是《兴趣文章》（Articles of Interest）的主持人和创作者，今天她来谈谈“Gorpcore”。那么艾弗里，你能告诉我什么是Gorpcore，它从哪里来吗？我觉得在隔离结束后，我们都从藏身处走出来，每个人都在问：发生了什么？伙计们，我们都在穿什么？答案就像是“Normcore”、“Barbiecore”、“Bistrocore”。就像是，到底发生了什么？但是
one of the earliest cores, this was 2015 was was Gorb core. And it was coined by, I believe, Jason Chan in the cut. And it's this concept of looking like you're going hiking when you're not. When you, you're wearing, you're wearing hiking shoes, you're wearing archerics, you know, sweat wicking windbreakers, you are wearing shorts that look like they should be rolled up
最早的“core”之一，这是2015年的，就是“Gorpcore”。它是由《The Cut》杂志的杰森·陈（Jason Chen）创造的。这是一个概念，即看起来像要去徒步旅行，但实际上并没有。当你穿着徒步鞋，穿着始祖鸟（Arc'teryx），你知道，排汗防风夹克，你穿着看起来应该卷起来的短裤，
with carabiners all over them. And you are just like walking your dog. You are dressed way more severely than you have to be. And I'm sure we'll talk about this, but there's a lot more gorp in all of our lives than we might know. And so this is both in people's everyday where they're wearing gorp gorp,
上面挂满了登山扣。而你只是在遛狗。你的穿着比实际需要要严肃得多。我相信我们会谈到这一点，但我们所有人的生活中都有比我们想象中更多的Gorp。所以这既存在于人们的日常穿着中，他们穿着Gorpcore，
but it's also like reaches the heights of high fashion as well, correct? Yes, yes, yes, especially, you know, again, like just before the pandemic, I mean, there was this moment where Virgil Abo showed up at New York Fashion Week wearing a Arcteric windbreaker, you know, to like sit front row at a runway show. And there have been all these collaborations between some high fashion brand and some outdoorsy brand. And they're just getting wilder and wilder. I believe it was a North facing Gucci and fashion world loves it. So Gorp Chor is a fairly new term. But this idea of dressing for the wilderness, even
但也达到了高级时装的高度，对吧？是的，是的，是的，特别是，你知道，再次强调，就在疫情之前，有一个时刻，维吉尔·阿布洛（Virgil Abloh）穿着始祖鸟防风夹克出现在纽约时装周，坐在秀场前排。而且所有这些高级时装品牌和户外品牌之间都有各种合作。它们变得越来越疯狂。我相信有北面（The North Face）和古驰（Gucci）的合作，时尚界很喜欢它。所以Gorpcore是一个相当新的词。但这种为荒野而打扮的想法，即使
if you aren't going to be in the wilderness is an old one. Can you tell me a little bit about the history of Gorp Kor? What Gorp Kor is depends on the era, right? But if you go way back in time and think about, you know, Teddy Roosevelt and what we thought American outdoorsmen looked like, that was kind of a form of Gorp Kor, which is to say, it was sort of a form of cosplay. And what I mean by that is like, there was this idea that the rugged American frontier man
你并不打算去荒野，却是一个古老的想法。你能告诉我一点Gorpcore的历史吗？Gorpcore是什么取决于时代，对吧？但如果你追溯到很久以前，想想泰迪·罗斯福（Teddy Roosevelt）以及我们认为美国户外运动者看起来是什么样子的，那其实就是一种Gorpcore，也就是说，它是一种角色扮演。我的意思是，当时有一种想法，认为粗犷的美国边疆人
wouldn't buy anything. He would make all his own stuff and he would find a deer and skin a deer and tan the leather and make his own suit. And that was like what real outdoorsy dudes did. And there were all these outdoorsmen magazines that were talking about how important it was to not buy your stuff pre-made and make it all yourself.
什么都不会买。他会自己制作所有的东西，他会找到一只鹿，剥下鹿皮，鞣制皮革，然后做成自己的套装。这就是真正的户外硬汉所做的事情。当时有各种各样的户外杂志，都在谈论不买现成的东西、全部自己制作是多么重要。
When most of those guys also did not make it themselves. Honestly, Teddy Roosevelt bought his buckskin suit from an indigenous woman, because that was who made those clothes. And so this idea that rugged Americans have always gone shopping, like our experience with the great outdoors has been mediated by buying stuff.
而大多数这些人其实并没有自己制作。老实说，泰迪·罗斯福是从一位原住民女性那里买了他的鹿皮套装，因为那是制作这些衣服的人。所以这种认为粗犷的美国人一直都在购物的想法，就像我们与大自然的体验一直是通过购买东西来调解的一样。
And ever since, over the course of, especially the 20th century, but really, you know, as early as the 1850s, really ever since the rise of mass produced clothes, the idea of like, can you buy the right stuff? Do you know what to buy has been a marker of experience and authenticity and expertise in the American outdoor leisure space. It's, it seems to me like from the very beginning, like right now, when you think of Gorpkort, you think of these high tech fabrics and they're always new when they're always stretchier and they're always like moisture wickier and all kinds of things are going on.
从那时起，在整个20世纪，但实际上，你知道，早在1850年代，自从大规模生产服装兴起以来，关于“你能买到合适的装备吗？你知道该买什么吗？”的想法，一直是美国户外休闲空间中经验、真实性和专业知识的标志。在我看来，从一开始，就像现在一样，当你想到Gorpcore时，你会想到这些高科技面料，它们总是新的，总是更有弹性，总是更排汗，各种各样的事情都在发生。
I believe that's the technical term. It's the most real clear. But it really is a fashion that's been obsessed with technology from the very beginning. Like it's always about the newest way to keep us from dry and comfortable. Can you talk about that from the start of it? Yeah. I mean, arguably, a huge part of Gorpkourt is the footwear. And I think nowadays it's most notable with what I think,
我相信那是专业术语。这是最清晰的。但这确实是一种从一开始就痴迷于技术的时尚。它总是关于最新的方式来保持我们的干爽和舒适。你能从头谈谈吗？是的。可以说，Gorpcore的很大一部分是鞋类。我认为如今它最引人注目的是，我认为，
sorry, are these really ugly shoes that everyone's so into, like these marbles and these salmons and these things that look very strange. And that really started in the 1920s with the L.O. Bean duck boot. That was considered the height of technology, this idea that before that, outdoorsmen were wearing moccasins
抱歉，是这些每个人都非常喜欢的丑鞋，比如这些迈乐（Merrells）和萨洛蒙（Salomons），以及这些看起来非常奇怪的东西。这确实始于1920年代的L.L.Bean鸭靴。那被认为是技术的巅峰，这种想法在之前，户外运动者穿的是鹿皮软鞋，
and it's like, oh my God, what if you went duck hunting and you could weigh it in the water and your feet would get less wet? And it's interesting because in early LLB catalog, they're really specific, they're really for the outdoorsmen, and they're really overtly about hunting.
然后就像是，噢天哪，如果你去猎鸭，你可以涉水，你的脚会少湿一点？这很有趣，因为在早期的L.L.Bean目录中，它们非常具体，它们确实是为户外运动者准备的，而且它们非常公开地是关于狩猎的。
And I believe the LLB catalog is like, second only to your gun, the most important thing for the outdoors is like your bean boots. And yes, that's sort of the origin of this idea that like there is a better way. You could be comfortable. Why wouldn't you just be more comfortable outdoors? Yeah, and a lot of these things that we recognize today got started sort of selling that
我相信L.L.Bean目录仅次于你的枪，是户外活动最重要的东西，就像你的Bean靴一样。是的，这就是这种想法的起源，即“有一种更好的方式”。你可以很舒适。为什么不在户外时更舒适呢？是的，我们今天认可的许多东西都是从销售那种
outdoorsy aesthetic. They were all sort of concentrated around this vibe with the outdoorsmen, like the whole scene in the stores and everything in the catalogs, can you just describe what they were going for? Yeah, I mean, one of the interesting things is like, Abercrombing Fitch was founded in 1892 and in 1904, they launched this multi-story headquarters in Manhattan and it is full of taxidermy. It is just like antlers everywhere. It is supposed to be a place for rugged outdoorsmen to get together and hang out.
户外美学开始的。它们都集中在户外运动者的氛围中，比如商店里的整个场景和目录里的一切，你能描述一下他们追求的是什么吗？是的，有趣的一点是，Abercrombie & Fitch成立于1892年，1904年，他们在曼哈顿推出了一个多层总部，里面全是动物标本。到处都是鹿角。它本应是一个让粗犷的户外运动者聚在一起消磨时光的地方。
And the interesting thing about Abercrombie and Fitches, as opposed to sort of the early outdoorsmen who are like, oh, you're supposed to make everything themselves, even though they very hypocritically did not actually do that. At Abercrombie and Fitch, one of their selling points was like, our salespeople are the best. They are all hunters. They are all hunters. They are all outdoorsmen.
Abercrombie & Fitch有趣的地方在于，与那些早期户外运动者说“噢，你应该自己制作一切”不同，尽管他们非常虚伪地并没有真正这样做。在Abercrombie & Fitch，他们的卖点之一是“我们的销售人员是最棒的。他们都是猎人。他们都是户外运动者。”
You should come to us and we will help you have a better outdoor trip. And this is the place to come and swap stories and swap tools and get kidded up for your next adventure. Which when you think about it, it was like the epitome of luxury. This is really before the National Park System expands to go to nature from New York City, even though it was probably really like the Bronx back then. You needed a car, you needed time, and you needed to have like many days. It was an incredible luxury. So this was
你应该来找我们，我们会帮你进行一次更好的户外旅行。这是来交换故事、交换工具并为下一次冒险做好装备的地方。当你想到这一点时，它是奢侈的缩影。这真的在国家公园系统扩张之前，从纽约市去大自然，尽管当时可能真的就像布朗克斯区一样。你需要一辆车，你需要时间，你需要有几天的时间。这是一种难以置信的奢侈。所以这
just considered the epitome of wealth. This was like the swanky thing. And so you can see this, this archetype of like the outdoor gentleman as this aspirational thing in late 1800s, early 1900s. And it's like on the cover of all the catalogs around this time, like the early Abercrampian fish catalogs, they're all illustrated. And it's always like a guy wrangling a fish with a jaunty pipe. You know, he's like a gentleman, outdoorsman, and that is considered like the ideal.
被认为是财富的缩影。这就像是时髦的东西。所以你可以看到这种“户外绅士”的原型作为一种抱负，在1800年代末、1900年代初。就像那个时期所有目录的封面上，比如早期的Abercrombie & Fitch目录，它们都是插图。总是像一个叼着俏皮烟斗的家伙在钓鱼。你知道，他就像一个绅士、户外运动者，这被认为是理想。
And you know, he's got a punch, like he's a comfortable and outdoor guy. I'm not sure you can wrangle a fish. Yeah, yeah. I mean, you should see that I should send you some of these illustrations. They are like a man like actively wrestling with nature in some capacity, like leaning out of his canoe to like grab a fit, you know, because sure he may be a gentleman hunter, but these stores were all incredibly niche.
而且你知道，他有一个酒壶，他是一个舒适的户外男人。我不确定你能否徒手抓鱼。是的，是的。我的意思是，你应该看看，我应该发给你一些这些插图。它们就像是一个男人在某种程度上积极地与大自然搏斗，比如从独木舟里探出身子去抓一条鱼，你知道，因为当然他可能是一个绅士猎人，但这些商店都非常小众。
These were incredibly rare. So anyone who was actually going out in nature did have to be sort of well versed and sort of experience. And that's part of why the knowledge of how to do all this stuff was just like the ultimate flex, you know, to say that you know how to how to defend for yourself out there in the wild was like, damn, you've done this a couple times. It's very impressive. Yeah, and I think it's interesting because the term Gorp Core is fairly new, but the need for this aesthetic and the high-tech underpinnings of this aesthetic has been around for a very long time, almost from the beginning, and this desire to constantly improve and make it
这些非常罕见。所以任何真正走进大自然的人都必须是见多识广且有经验的。这就是为什么知道如何做所有这些事情的知识就像是终极炫耀，你知道，说你知道如何在野外生存，就像是“天哪，你已经做过几次了”。这非常令人印象深刻。是的，我认为这很有趣，因为Gorpcore这个词相当新，但对这种美学的需求以及这种美学背后的高科技基础已经存在了很长时间，几乎从一开始就是这样，这种不断改进和让它
service better goes back to the very beginning of what could be considered gorp core. I mean, the funny thing is now arguably, I think. I mean, say whatever you want about gorp core is a fashion trend. I don't partake, but philosophically, I really like that it is saying that the city is also nature. We also want to be dry and comfortable walking the dog or going to buy eggs at the corner store. Like we also live in the environment, the man-made environment, but it's still, it's not like we have this fancy costume change to go out and take a walk. It's, I kind of, I think that's a bit more
服务更好的渴望可以追溯到可以被认为是Gorpcore的最初。我的意思是，有趣的是，现在可以说，我想。我的意思是，无论你怎么说Gorpcore作为一种时尚潮流。我不参与，但在哲学上，我真的很喜欢它说“城市也是大自然”。我们在遛狗或去街角商店买鸡蛋时也想保持干爽和舒适。就像我们也生活在环境中，人造环境中，但这并不是说我们为了出去散步还要换上一套华丽的服装。这，我有点，我认为这在
start-torially honest. Well, I'm totally fascinated by this history and I take it, you have been fascinated by this history too. I take it, this is a part of a new series. You guessed correctly, this is going to be the next multi-part season of Articles of Interest, and it is so fascinating. Yeah. It goes way beyond Gorpcore. It's like all of our clothes. Awesome. Well, I can't wait to listen to it. Thank you so much, Avery. Thanks, Roman. This is fun. Our final trail story, at least for today, is after the break.
服装上更诚实。好吧，我完全被这段历史迷住了，我想你也被这段历史迷住了。我想这是新系列的一部分。你猜对了，这将是《兴趣文章》的下一个多部分季节，它太迷人了。是的。它远远超出了Gorpcore。它就像我们所有的衣服。太棒了。好吧，我迫不及待想听了。非常感谢你，艾弗里。谢谢，罗曼。这很有趣。我们最后的步道故事，至少是今天的，在休息之后。
Our final trail story of the day is about something many of us can relate to, longing to get back on a favorite trail. Here is 99Pi producer Jason Dillion. I spent the first few months of this year curled up on the couch with my dog Hazel. She's my first dog, a spirited 60-pound black German shepherd mix with a stick-lush coat and these pearly white markings on her chest and paws. Normally, Hazel is a pretty active dog. She loves chasing rabbits out of the garden and playing keep away with me in the backyard.
我们今天最后的步道故事是关于我们许多人都能产生共鸣的事情：渴望回到一条最喜欢的步道上。这是99Pi制作人杰森·迪利恩（Jason Dillion）。今年头几个月，我一直和我的狗黑兹尔（Hazel）蜷缩在沙发上。她是我的第一只狗，一只精力充沛、60磅重的黑色德国牧羊犬混血，有着浓密的毛发，胸部和爪子上有珍珠白色的斑纹。通常，黑兹尔是一只非常活跃的狗。她喜欢在花园里追逐兔子，喜欢在后院和我玩抢球游戏。
Hey, no, drop it. Drop it is. But back in February, Hazel had to go on crate rest. A neurologist diagnosed her with a rare birth defect in her back, and she needed surgery. The operation left her with this gnarly scar that stretched from the base of her tail up into the middle of her torso, nearly 8 inches of tissue that got sliced through, and then stitched back together like the seams of a baseball. At night, my wife and I took turns lying down next to her. Sometimes, Hazel would be stretched out on her side, loudly snoring.
嘿，不，放下。放下。但在二月，黑兹尔不得不进行笼养休息。神经科医生诊断出她背部有一种罕见的先天缺陷，她需要手术。手术给她留下了一道狰狞的伤疤，从尾巴根部一直延伸到躯干中部，近8英寸的组织被切开，然后像棒球的接缝一样缝合在一起。晚上，我和妻子轮流躺在她身边。有时，黑兹尔会侧身伸展，大声打呼噜。
Other times, she'd be running in her sleep. And it's this little twitch of the paws that gave me and my wife some relief, because we both knew exactly where Hazel was dreaming of running. Hi, Lowe, let's go! Oh, here they come. Stella gets very jealous when everybody goes in plays in the water and Sinanchi can't get to them. This is John Burnett, but honestly I only learned that recently. For over a year we refer to each other by our dog's names, so to me John was Stella, Arlo,
其他时候，她会在睡梦中奔跑。正是爪子的这种小抽动让我和妻子感到一丝宽慰，因为我们都知道黑兹尔梦见在哪里奔跑。嗨，阿洛，我们走吧！噢，他们来了。当每个人都去水里玩而辛安奇（Sinanchi）够不到他们时，斯特拉（Stella）会非常嫉妒。这是约翰·伯内特（John Burnett），但老实说我最近才知道。一年多来，我们一直用狗的名字称呼对方，所以对我来说，约翰就是斯特拉、阿洛、
and Freddie's dad. It's actually Arlo Guthrie, Freddie Mercury, and Stella like from street cars. Stella! John is one of a dozen or so other dog parents that I've gotten to know while walking Hazel on her favorite trail. It sits about a mile down the road from us on the south side of Providence, Rhode Island. Before the surgery, Hazel and I used to come back here every morning. The main entrance has this dark brown wooden bridge that leads to a series of paths which
和弗雷迪的爸爸。其实是阿洛·格思里（Arlo Guthrie）、弗雷迪·默丘里（Freddie Mercury）和斯特拉，就像《欲望号街车》里的斯特拉。斯特拉！约翰是我在带黑兹尔走她最喜欢的步道时认识的十几位狗主人之一。它离我们在罗德岛州普罗维登斯南部的路大约一英里。手术前，黑兹尔和我每天早上都会来这里。主入口有一座深棕色的木桥，通向一系列路径，这些路径
run parallel and butt up against the river. At first, the whole thing looks pretty unexceptional, overgrown with knotweed, brambles, and a few decent sized patches of poison ivy. Most of it is unmarked too, and so for the uninitiated, it may not seem like much of a trail at all, but for the neighborhood dogs these paths are everything. So this is now our thing every, basically every day. We're in here and sometimes twice a day. Caroline brought the dogs out last evening to go for a swim.
平行于河流并紧挨着河流。起初，这一切看起来相当普通，长满了虎杖、荆棘和几片像样的毒葛。大部分地方也没有标记，所以对于外行来说，它看起来根本不像一条步道，但对于社区里的狗来说，这些路径就是一切。所以这现在是我们每天必做的事情。我们在这里，有时一天两次。卡罗琳（Caroline）昨晚带狗出来游泳。
John told me that over 60 years ago, the entrance to the path used to be a paved walkway to a local business where residents could rent canoes and go rowing. But once that closed down and the pavement got ripped up, the trail became less a way to get from here to there and more the destination itself. If the trail is the destination, the dogs are the reason for the trip. There's nothing quite like seeing six, seven, or even on a good date, 10 dogs just ripping it through the woods.
约翰告诉我，60多年前，这条小径的入口曾经是一条通往当地企业的铺砌人行道，居民们可以在那里租独木舟划船。但一旦那里关闭，路面被拆除，这条步道就不再是从这里到那里的途径，而更多地成为了目的地本身。如果步道是目的地，那么狗就是旅行的原因。没有什么比看到六、七只，甚至在好日子里有10只狗在树林里奔跑更棒的了。
The first few times we brought Hazel to the trail, she'd cross the bridge with her nose to the dirt, trying to smell the other dogs up ahead. In the summer, the beach is usually where her nose leads us. A spot where two paths converge is usually where her nose leads us, a spot where two paths converge on the Patuxet River and form a little patch of land for the dogs to fetch sticks in the water. The rivers named after the Patuxet band of the Narragantid tribe, who for generations lived in this area and found nourishment in these waters. But the land was colonized, and before long chemical plants and other upstream polluters started dumping ungodly amounts of noxious waste into the river. The people who lived in towns along the banks of the Patuxet spoke of a dark, foul smelling
前几次我们带黑兹尔去步道时，她会用鼻子贴着泥土过桥，试图闻闻前面其他狗的味道。夏天，海滩通常是她鼻子指引我们去的地方。两条路径汇合的地方通常是她鼻子指引我们去的地方，在帕塔克塞特河（Patuxet River）上形成了一小块土地，供狗在水里捡木棍。这条河以纳拉甘西特部落（Narragansett tribe）的帕塔克塞特支派命名，他们世世代代居住在这个地区，并从这些水域中获得滋养。但土地被殖民了，不久之后，化工厂和其他上游污染者开始向河里倾倒难以置信的有害废物。住在帕塔克塞特河岸边城镇的人们谈论着一种黑暗、恶臭的
deposit that washed up on their shores. For a long time, it was known as the dirtiest river in Rhode Island. Somehow still managing to be exceptional, even in a state chock full of polluted waterways. While there's still a lot more work to do, it's true that over the last few decades, the water quality has improved. And that's in large part thanks to the people in the area who've become stewards, not only of the river, but of the past that have been carved all around it. People in the woods here, a lot of people just kind of do their thing.
沉积物冲上了他们的海岸。很长一段时间里，它被称为罗德岛最脏的河流。不知何故，即使在一个充满污染水道的州，它仍然设法表现得“出类拔萃”。虽然还有很多工作要做，但确实在过去几十年里，水质有所改善。这在很大程度上要归功于该地区的人们，他们不仅成为了河流的守护者，也成为了周围开辟出的路径的守护者。树林里的人，很多人只是做他们自己的事。
They don't talk about it, and they don't ask for feedback or affirmation. They just come along and they'll trim a tree or pick up some trash or clean out some garbage because it's just the right thing to do. In addition to walking his dogs back here, John is also one of a group of people who helps keep the trail and walking shape for the rest of us. When I caught up with him, he was trimming back some invasive plants that have made a tiny canopy on the root to the water, which honestly looked kind of nice, but John reminded me that it was a mega hotbed for ticks. So this is kind of a
他们不谈论它，也不寻求反馈或肯定。他们只是走过来，修剪一棵树，捡起一些垃圾，或者清理一些废弃物，因为这是正确的事情。除了在这里遛狗，约翰还是帮助我们其他人保持步道步行状态的一群人之一。当我追上他时，他正在修剪一些入侵植物，这些植物在通往水的路上形成了一个小小的树冠，老实说看起来还不错，但约翰提醒我，那是蜱虫的超级温床。所以这是一种
hands-on thing that I I can do and feel good about and I know that other people in the woods really value it. It's the least I can do to take care of a place that I care so much about. In the months Hazel spent recovering from surgery, I hadn't gone to the trail once. Neither had my wife. We missed talking with John and the rest of our trail friends, and we really missed the dogs. We wondered whether some of the older ones like Ozzy had made it through the winter, whether Hazel would still be able to wrestle with her best friend Bowie the way she used to. And one morning in the
我可以做并感觉良好的亲力亲为的事情，我知道树林里的其他人真的很看重它。照顾一个我如此关心的地方，这是我能做的最起码的事情。在黑兹尔手术恢复的几个月里，我一次也没去过步道。我妻子也没去过。我们很想念和约翰以及其他步道朋友聊天，我们真的很想念那些狗。我们想知道像奥兹（Ozzy）这样年长的狗是否熬过了冬天，黑兹尔是否还能像以前那样和她最好的朋友鲍伊（Bowie）摔跤。有一天早上，在
late spring, after Hazel built herself back up, it was finally time to find out. The three of us piled into the car for the short drive to the trail. As we got closer, I could see in the rear view Hazel's eyes beaming. Her tail wagging, almost twitching with anticipation. When we arrived and opened the car door, Hazel bolted out, running towards her friend's Bowie and Ozzie. Oh, there she goes. My goodness Ozzy you're excited.
春末，黑兹尔恢复体力后，终于到了揭晓答案的时候了。我们三个挤进车里，短途开车前往步道。当我们靠近时，我从后视镜里看到黑兹尔的眼睛在发光。她的尾巴摇摆着，几乎因为期待而抽动。当我们到达并打开车门时，黑兹尔冲了出去，跑向她的朋友鲍伊和奥兹。噢，她去了。天哪，奥兹，你真兴奋。
These days we're back to walk in the trail every morning and Hazel cannot be more thrilled. to walk in the trail every morning and Hazel cannot be more thrilled. Hazel! Here's a U-swimming! Oh, look at that, it's doing a little water therapy. She's once again running up and down this path that's been worn in not only by generations of people who've walked through, but by the way to the love that we each carry for our most loyal friends. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jason Dillion, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Maldonado Medina, and Kelly Prime, edited by Kelly Prime, who would like to note that her friends Nina
这些天我们又恢复了每天早上在小径上散步，Hazel 简直高兴坏了。Hazel！看那儿，有一只水獭！噢，快看，它在做水疗呢。她又一次在这条小路上跑上跑下，这条路不仅是几代人走出来的，更是我们每个人对最忠诚的朋友所怀有的爱所铺就的。本周的《99% Invisible》由 Jason Dillion、Lashma Dawn、Jacob Maldonado Medina 和 Kelly Prime 制作，Kelly Prime 负责编辑，她想特别提到她的朋友 Nina
Loro and Michael Samson did very valiantly end up biking the Empire State Trail through the downpour all the way back to New York City. Only she went out and took the train. Sound makes by Martin Gonzales, music by a director of Sound Swan Rihall. Delaney Hall as the senior editor, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barrupe, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, Christopher Johnson, intern Anna Castanero, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence, an extra special thanks this week to Dr. Parsley, who helped get Hazel back on the trail.
Loro 和 Michael Samson 非常勇敢地冒着倾盆大雨骑行了帝国州小径，一路骑回了纽约市。只有她中途放弃，改坐了火车。音效由 Martin Gonzales 制作，音乐由声音总监 Swan Rihall 负责。Delaney Hall 是高级编辑，Kurt Colstead 是数字总监。团队其他成员包括 Chris Barrupe、Emmett Fitzgerald、Vivian Leigh、Joe Rosenberg、Christopher Johnson、实习生 Anna Castanero 以及我 Roman Mars。《99% Invisible》的标志由 Stefan Lawrence 设计，本周要特别感谢 Parsley 医生，他帮助 Hazel 回到了小径上。
We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的 Pandora 大楼，坐落在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在 Facebook 上找到我们的节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上关注我 @RomanMars 或关注节目 @99PIorg。我们也在 Instagram、Reddit 和 TikTok 上。你可以在 99PI.org 找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目链接，以及《99% Invisible》的所有往期节目。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。